every year in February the theater on
potsdamer platz turns into the Berlin
Ollie palace
[Applause]
this year those gracing the red carpet
will include Catherine Deneuve Penelope
Cruz Hugh Jackman and Robert Pattinson
Berlin loves celebrities and they love
Berlin
film buffs are already unrolling their
sleeping mats to make sure they can get
tickets some tickets are sold online but
most are available at the box office
three days before each screening that
means queuing I wasn't ready at least
was three hours but I was in front of
the queue
Berlin has its own feel it has its own
energy and so that also gets translated
into the film festival it's a very
different cinema experience
it's not about popcorn but about real
film buffs coming together
speaking of popcorn one of the many
Berlin festival sections is culinary
cinema first a film featuring food is
sprayed and afterwards gourmet chefs
serve a menu inspired by it if that's
too straight-laced for you it's off to
the Berlin alley parties
they take place all over the city
[Music]
this is where the industry insiders meet
it's all about seeing and being seen
it's also ideal for autograph hunters
there's just one catch you need an
invitation or put on your glad rags and
take your chances it might work but
watch it getting there can be quite
slippery